I'm talking to mr. Clifton
eng who worked as
a holder up on the arch of the sydney
harbour bridge on the north side. Do you
remember when you first got the job there.
Do you mr. Yes i remember. I work with
a fellow named mick higgins he came up to
the hawkesbury river bridge where i was
working and asked me would i come down
and hold up for him i said yes. Make
higgins was it worked with you before. How
do you only around the docks in casual
work and how did you get taken on
by when you got down to the bridge
so long ago i can't remember can't
remember names that but i think it was
a fellow named sam harris who was
foreman on my side. How many
boilermakers and were there on your side.
Remember but i'd only have to have
a guess. When i first started on it.
I think there was only about half
a dozen. And i think. Then again i'm now
a large i don't think there was between
a hundred and undried fifty
i wouldn't say that's
a rough guess what are you to do you start
the in december nineteen twenty seven.
You're right in from the start then did you
go on the approaches before you got on
the arch i we're doing
a little bit of work on their approach
as yes that's the approach spans and
approach bands. Was that easy work or
well it was no there's nothing easy about
the job you know and you're up in the air
and got to keep your wits about you. So
you wouldn't for but there's nothing
easy about the harbour bridge. Working
contract. And. The contractors
were always hard with
a hard but fair they never embarrassed
it's you know but as long as you got to be
capable and do your work and i never worried
you know how did you get up there in
the morning. We we climbed
up. By ladder which is
which was attached to the first columns and
and did it never went up in the cradle
. Oh later on this. You've got over the
water we did go up in the crater yes you
are going up in the cradle. Yes. Yes you
the better the first time which is the
swing
a bit you know we are around on the ball
of the hook but because he get used to it
. Can you tell me about the job of
holding up exactly what it what it
entails. Yes well you get that the
river. They get the river from
the corker. And you get
a you get you get the rev it has get it as
hot as you can and you've got to be very
quick get into the house get your machine
which air driven and push it and get your
machine onto it and. And and then you have
a little lever that gives the rattler
to it and then the boilermaker gets an
e i were both rattling and then he knocks
it down and finishes that off on the
other side and the boilermaker normally
gets you on the inside. If you can and as
me i will. In most cases you have got to
be in the inside but there is times when
they're doing the batch of rivets there's
two parts at two chords together and
they've got to be riveted inside and these
inside with me but most times these
outside and i'm always inside.
In dull days you didn't have much light in
there and you were working on the grade
as. As it was going up very hard
on your legs. And yet to watch the
sparks and the metal
from the river. There's
a come down and from then on you'd
work that way. Was it. Cold
in the winter in the very cold very
cold indeed and hot in the summer.
Especially in the afternoons i suppose. Yes
yes. Do you remember the smell of paint
in there. Oh yeah. So you've always always
had that because they always had fellow
come and painting the edge of the river.
Since you know as you finished it. You
know there's always
a smell of that around inside
that was led paint when it wasn't
a pleasant smell but coarse sort of get
used to everything. Some of the fellows
talked about the shop drillings which used
to get stuck in the paint as well. You
were run across that you would. Now and
again you know but you overcome it.
Do these issues gloves in those
days now gloves. You had your own.
I have to think. Now they may
have had. I'm not too sure
a long while ago. But i would say most times
we never had gloves because it was too
awkward working with them you know
the boilermakers nearly always had
a riveters normally i was hoped loves their
ad that gun in their hand all the time
you know they'd have to have their left
hand. Anyway. But you got the gun in your
hand on the other side do. Yes i did.
Well i may have had one i can't remember.
Then i think else you remember about being
inside the courts you remember thinking
about when the plaything used
to shake sometimes. Oh yes.
Sometimes. And when she got right out in
the in in the hard ruins that were blowing
she'd sway
a little but mostly when they were bringing
up. Different parts of the bridge to be
riveted. And they were getting them into
place they'd knock against each and she
would shake
a bit then it wasn't very pleasant but
it makes you think about the cables
. Yes i used to often i had my
mind was on the cables quite
a lot. I used to think with all this weight.
And i hope that's cement held i mean
in the rock you know and i was always
a little bit doubtful whether that how
would you know but i put my. I give the
benefit to the engineers. And several
people have said that they got in their
imagination and they thought when it used
to shake. Do you remember what used what
it used to feel like when they started
moving the creeper crane that really didn't
worry me because the creeper crane was ahead
of us and we were at the back riveting
behind it it didn't shake the arch that
you shake when it moved. No they didn't.
That didn't worry is not
a good. That was ok. Do you did you talk
to any of the engineers about the cables
now. No i don't think i never talk to
any engineers now. Do you member any
accidents while you were working on the
bridge. Oh yes i'm not too sure was out in
the fourth or fifth panel and we were
working in the stitching played underneath
and underneath the cord and they
were working up above screwing
screwing a job up. And all of
a sudden i see something got caught
in the eye and i thought it was
a bag of bolts. Going by but then i heard
a commotion and then look and something was
wrong. I thought and i looked over and
i just seen
a fellow just hit the water. And he
disappeared for about one or two minutes
and then floated to the top with his head
and i and stretched looking down into the
water. And i suppose
a minute or two was like that and then he
disappeared. I think they got his body
the next day. Did you know him.
Yes i did know him. Is only
a young fellow about twenty five or so
and an englishman. Do members know. Yes
addison was his name. No
first no. I can't remember.
Then used it was used
to say they called him
a nipper oh yes yes. Yep around us and
years ago i remember it now you've got to
bring them names to me now. So long ago.
Remember stan london dear yes yes i
remember his name he was
a boilermaker he was the addison's paul
america and he's still living in newcastle
now. Yeah still living. How would he
be she said i think he would be eighty
just doesn't look at all these blind
blind luck is i think you had detached
retinas and its eyes is absolutely blind
he would you try to get things fixed up
but no he couldn't ever do anything. It
is burning in cambridge credits to. There
was another fellow working alongside them
where they were screaming and billy beggs
i met him at the turnout
over blues point. Billy
biggs was
a record was me boilermaker and he worked
also on the north side. Yes he was on the
north side right through. He lives at
french's forest. That's right. Who are short
of people on the south side and that's
a fact. Do you remember any of the scene
here is the rigors at all who still
a wreck to the steel. I remember
i don't know their names as
a little french fella. I
think harris was was was
a number one rigger he
was a foreman rigger
a little frenchman very
little fellow he was
a very capable and i just can't run call
their names too long ago and i think you.
Can you do you remember ever remember being
scared. While you working on the bridge
. Well i did have a thrill. If
you caught it scared the bit of
a thrill. I had to go up and we were working
on. Some little job was on the job.
I just can't remember but i know i had to
get right about three quarter way up to
the top. I think it was to check on
a couple of boats. I can't remember when
i got up there. I just noticed up the
harbor big clouds coming down just like.
And i thought to myself this is going to
be good and all of
a sudden it hit us westerly gale and all i
just sat there were hanging on for about
a quarter of an hour twenty minutes and i
didn't subside much but i worked my way
down. Glad to get down as the photographer
said about that he said the used to
watch the observatory
because they used to drive
a black ball when it's done so that he
was coming. Yes. Do you remember another
time when you were up the top. We used to
see all sorts of things there. I remember
one day and
a beautiful beautiful summer
day and very clear and
you could see under the water quite
quite a lot. All of a sudden we've seen
a big form
a form must have been twenty years
thirty feet long. I'm sure. And it was
a whale and he had barnacles on him miss
we put our couldn't get out of the harbor
i believe and i noticed
a stand. Aj launch which is to take the
boy used to take the workers over to the
ships they were following him around with
a photographer this. Every time he came
up they sort of spurted spurted water
which the whales do.
When they lost him for
a while but we seen him and we seen him
coming up up up and i see it come right
under their launch and nearly tipped it
up. But that was the end of taking the
photos of the whale they went for their
life. Good incident was remember any others
do you. Just think well the
working conditions like on that
job. Well the money wasn't
bad in them days we got £10
a week. I think a well i think
a tradesman on the ground in most most
jobs around sydney were i think it
was about £4 eighteen a week. So
we were getting £10 we got £10
a week for the first seven panels
and the next seven panels we got
a rise of seven shillings £10 seven hour
a minute. These are was. We were never had
any amenities we just hang our close up
. Got into our overalls
up we went no morning tea
where the climb down for dinner
when we come down by by the
by the cage but. Do
you ever adore and long being harder than
any other employer. Well i said no they
weren't hard but you know as long as you're
done your work. They didn't trouble you
but you had to do your work and keep
working. No no don't get in groups and talk
you've just done your work because
they were contracting for
a job. No i can't say they were fair but
you know i had to do your work. I knew
what they were doing that absolutely
they knew what they were doing. Yes. But
getting back to your men at these
assumed you got down oh it was
a one tap there i think and you just washed
your hands. You didn't you went out.
Pretty grubby. But you do up
a top if you want to go the toilet. Well
nature took its course and it was over the
side or the other way. You know you have
to go down but you seem to get used to
didn't happen much i think you've
got used to nature you know.
Well do you remember any union meetings
or industrial action there were
a few meetings but i can't remember. I
never remember any strike so i think there
was something to do with the crane drive
a couple of times but i don't think
were involved in any strikes
a clear of them. I think. Do you remember
the vegetation for the hope money.
Yes there was there was
a some agitation for that for that but
right through. I don't think we had
a lot of trouble. To member the
union meetings here so remember
a couple but still far i can't remember
what went on. You know it was too far too
long ago. Do you remember the closing of
the arch to yes but i was an up there at
the time i think i got my dismissal before
a while while they were working on that
because you couldn't have them all up there
and most of the riveting was
done done to there but i was
a little bit disappointed iceberg because
i was there from the onset of the arch
but somebody had to go. I think and i
was just one of them. Jim we're getting
canberra to bob it is and
they rewarded us with
a can better or two shillings. But i don't
think i had it long because the pressure
is on them and it was very valuable for me
to spend what happened to you then. Did
you get
a job. I worked along the waterfront for the
for about three or four years i suppose
just getting a few weeks
there in a day and
a day there in the trade and
then i've got a job and as
a conductor and driving and driving trams.
So i never went back to the ironworkers
. Were you on the dole ever. Yes i was on
the dole with plenty of others. And very
good very talented men were on the dole
in them days. No work for them. You know
what the dole was when you were on it. Yes
i think we got at first we had so we got
a list of groceries you could
have i think it was the value of
a leavens of eleven shillings
a couple and you had to have what was on
paper but they done away with that and you
could just pick what you wanted after that
jeff remembered getting your you dole in
kind
a bigger one. Do you remember getting it
doll in groceries rather than rather than
coupons even yes i do remember that. Yes.
Where did you go to get it. Well i was
there used to be down it down at the
wharf just near that wasn't far from the
bridge. We went with there
we got some meat and
a few loaves of bread. We ate the walk
down for my card to get it. And then world
work more never the three of us to pay
the fare. And what did you do about the
money for cooking. Well where i was
living with my mother and father in law.
Like most people they families were living
together and you just settled on the way
you could you didn't have to worry about
rent therefore now didn't have to worry
about rent. Do you think
else about those times. Yes
. The council used to at
times i used to give you
a fortnight work working and for the
council probably working on the roads or
making gutters and things like that. Get
a fortnight's wages and you put your of
the dole for three weeks. You couldn't
apply for the dole for three
weeks after that but was that
a new law of rates and that helped you to
pay the rates the house did you had to do
that for you and mother didn't lauded you
as i had to do that. So as my mother look
at power rage because her husband wasn't
working ever to member any other things
about those times. In them times
in the depression. Yet he
had go down to go down around the different
places of docs in places and you stand
about four hours. You might just
to get a day's work or half
a day's work you lined up every day there
was nowhere else to go and just with just
the hope that you'd get
a bit of work but that was hard but you
got used to it was that what they call
towing the line that was right that
was towing a line. And how many times
a day to do you turn the line morning
and in a time twice a day twice
a day. To remove the accuracy with which
the work had to be done. Yes i remember
that because where i was putting the where
i had to put the rivets into the house
that the be accurate because they were long
rivets. And very rarely get one out of
position and if there was one out of
position we had to drift it putting
a drift in and knocking it
through with a to seven or
a fourteen pound hammer but i'd say right
through that the work their accuracy
was practically almost a hundred per cent.
. Do you remember by comparison to other
work. It was much better much better in
their work in the in. In the dockyards
and in them places. You know using
drifts quite a lot and they were
reaming house but there wasn't
a ream are on their job.
There wasn't supposed to be
a heavy drift over. Well
you had to help yourself
a little. Do you remember the inspectors
do. Yes they used to come around with
their little hammer after it finished
a cord. And they tap everyone you
know you'd get off a couple get
a few to be cut out and then when they had
to be cut out the boilermaker they have
just. He had a little machine something
like a caulking machine and they put
a diamond shaped tool into that and they
cut right through the head of the rivet.
And then it reverse it and put it on another
snap one half of it off the other half
. We would have to put a point on it at
a point whether with the handle. He
put it on and i'd knock it off with
a hammer and then we'd not but
through and replace it with
a good rivet. Do you have many now
we didn't have many pretty good.
They were screwed up the jobs are screwed
up pretty good. Who was your assembly
going going ahead of you. Oh i can't
remember their names and no chance. I
can't remember names and you know how many
what was there in there and whether in
a riveting three you know the river huda
hole or up in the boilermaker that's on
the arch. Yes. And the shops that were
more. Well i don't know anything about the
shops i never worked in there. And
how many were there in assembly.
You mean riggers and no
there were well i think.
Oh well i think on our job on jobs we
were i think the two or three gangs of
of bowling up gangs of two men with
their be an ironworker and to go
boil and make
a nine worker. And then the painters going
around touching up the rivets were they
part of the gang or were they separate now
they weren't part the gang there were
just separate catching up. I
think it was oh and work was
a touch them up there you know red led and
that sort of stuff but just to preserve
them. You did you didn't have anything to
do with the erection side of things. Did
you now. Now do you member the seal
a writers oh yes they were
pretty fearless fellas. Yes
they were
a select band of their own they were very
very good member of the crane drivers at
all but i much about the cry and i
was only seen a mike there like
a little there little head up above
you know we weren't connected with
a match. You know you don't remember how
many references you had you don't remember
how many of that crane drivers on each
creature crane there were do you. I
think there was only one one driver was i
think there has to be four but anyway.
Well i tell you i don't know i don't know
any about the drivers or not i wouldn't
know. Well i suggest trying to get at
a point just just bear with me because i
had no actual evidence that there were
four people said they were might have been
through the matter before but when you
come to think of it. Now
there's two there's
a main creeper crane driver he was on the
on the creeper crown on the front. We had
two main controls apart from having the
crane around there was one was the. The
main left and the other was what is known
as the jigger hoist and that worked off
together so they could one of the point of
balance and one at the lower end so they
could lift something at an angle. It was
a creeper crane's job and there was another
little cry and you slipped you in the
cradle on the front. Yes i remember the
one that used to pull us up. On the cage
yes i remember that fella. He used to go.
Well our resignedly. He said travis on
attached to the big crane. So that's two
for sure if it's your now on the back now
when you were wanting your tools and bits
and pieces up you there was two more on
the back wasn't jackson that happened
to addison do you remember him
much before that i mean we missed
a week or two before that he slipped this
other time i didn't notice what he did
probably screwing up and he tumbled down
but he didn't go over the court this day.
It fell fell against the post i thought he
was very lucky that day. Whether the man
was careless or didn't keep his mind on
the job. I did well i would like to say.
Do you remember him. Do you no were very
well do you know i know well you're just
working amongst you but i don't think it
was until long and the job when he fell
i'm not too sure but he was an englishman
but i didn't speak to him much just given
the time of the day you know he was just
married was now i believe he was yes
but. During different nationalities of
the people who worked on the bridge.
Well there were englishmen irishmen
scotchman of course australians.
I remember little of rigor frenchmen
and seemed to be the norwegians or
swedes and i think germans as far as
i could make out but there was quite
a mixture. For the united nations with
the rigours where they. Yeah the united
nations of the region were eggers but they
were they were very good very good at
the bay. No wildmen some of them too. I
understand. Yes well on an off night
not on really big because you couldn't
be while you keep your wits about you
. Where were you born cliff. I
was born in balmain the home of
shipbuilding and ship building repairs
you know what lies. I suppose i
fell into what naturally most most people
around there work in the docks and that
type of thing you know i was
apprentices. Early in my life as
a shipwright but the fellow i was working
with went broke and i never followed
that up. I just followed up the docks then
and did casual work. Working with the
monks boilermakers and iron
workers and then on. So i
just battle along. When you leave
school. I left skill and i was fourteen
and he went straight out of the tivoli
apprenticeship right now. I was working on
my first job was working with
a fella making confetti. And then another
place i worked putting threads on
nuts and nuts and bolts and then
i think i went went in as an
apprentice ship right but as i say i never
followed up when the fellow went broke.
Do you remember how do you wind up in the
whole spirit. Oh well i was working for
the railway there as i was only
a junior when i was working at the railway
i was working for the them putting them
. Overhead overhead department
you know electric stations.
I was working on the steel work but there
and when i turned twenty one. They put me
off and i applied for
a job and they were to be river bridge and
i got it i suppose i was up there about
. Nine months of something and then that's
how i got the job on harbour bridge when
micky gyns approach me.
Who was making begins was
a very wild man he was
a boxer in his early days very
wild and dangerous to work with
he had
a very vile temper. I don't know
why i come to get away from him.
I can't remember whether i whether he left
on the bridge. I don't i know he didn't
stay on the bridge. Too long because he'd
i think he'd get into holes where there
with the management he
was a hard man to hold
a job and that's how i come to work
with this scotchman who was his name.
I worked with him for over two years and i
can't remember his name. Do you remember
any other boilermakers that are well known
around the place who you work with. Well
i was billy beg's there and there was
a knee ellis he was on the southern
side he worked in the docks and i'm
a doctor there. And the
fellow name. He was
it was
a church man i can't think of his name
but very religious and i think he was
a type of church minister a funny
sort of a job for him to evers
a boilermaker amongst tough men.
And i just can't remember his name
a quote or some name like that was in the
salvation army. No i don't think it was
a salvation army was in the i don't
know what denomination but it's hard
it's hard to think of
a try and remember the name just
too long ago for me i haven't got
a good memory. Do you remember any of the
job delegates you were and worker when
you. Yes. I doubt i can't remember the
worker delicates but i can remember the
boilermaker delegate he was doyle he was an
irishman a bit of
a wild man. Can't remember my
delicate you did you later on
become become
a boilermaker to do you now. Now i went
from there to tram driving and finished up
as a linesman for the
transport department.